>> So let's assume that we're using
semantic network as a representation for
this particular class of problem.
Given that, how would you apply generate
and matter to this problem, David?
>> So it sounds like would
I would do is I would
use the transformation between A and B,
transfer that transformation to C and
use it to generate my answer for D.
I then take my answer for D and compare
it against 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 and 6 and
see which one most closely
matched what I generated.
If I wanted to make my tester and
generator even smarter,
I might say that in order
to be the correct answer,
it has to meet the generated answer
with a certain level of confidence.
And if it doesn't meet that level of
confidence, it should go back and see if
there's a different transformation
we could have transferred.
That would take care of the problem
earlier where either the middle shape
disappeared or
the outer shape disappeared.
>> That's a good answer, David.
It is another way of
solving this problem.
It is another way of solving
this problem using test and
semantic networks.
One could take one, put it under D.
Generate the transformation
from C to D and
then test it against
the transformation from A to B.
One could do the same thing with 2,
put 2 here into D,
directly transformation tested
against the transformation A to B.
One could do this for
all six choices and then find out, which
one of these transformations is closest
with the transformation from A to B.
Thus, in this problem, one can use
[INAUDIBLE] test methods in two very
different ways, all of the knowledge
representation ribbon is the same.
So knowledge representation captures
some knowledge about the world
at a level of abstraction.
It is coupled with problem
solving methods, but
more than one problem solving method,
more than one variation of a problem
solving method might be applicable
using technology representation.